segunda Crónica de economía del día y
última de la semana de nuevo con nuestro
compañero Juan Pablo lucume bienvenido
acá estamos para cerrar la semana como
es pues hay que cerrarla lo grande y
vamos a empezar encerrando cerrando no
encerrando con Rusia porque parece que
las sanciones de occidente no han
afectado tanto a su economía Así es
Rodrigo al menos no al nivel que Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea esperaban no
generó el efecto que ellos buscaban
desde el inicio Por qué pues las
exportaciones de petróleo ruso alcanzan
en marzo su nivel más alto en tres años
según informó este viernes la agencia
internacional de energía en los números
los envíos totales de Rusia aumentaron
600.000 barriles de petróleo por día
hasta llegar a un total de 8,1 millones
de barriles de petróleo por día en marzo
el nivel más alto desde abril de 2020
como lo estamos viendo en el gráfico y
también hay otras precisiones los
ingresos están 43% por debajo si se
compara con el año anterior y los envíos
a la Unión Europea se duplicaron entre
en febrero y marzo a 300.000 barriles de
petróleo pues diarios por día pese a
esto Pues los ingresos también en el
ámbito cayeron considerablemente pues
aunque tuvieron una pequeña recuperación
como decíamos todavía está Pues en el
43% bueno interesante y además es
interesante también que las previsiones
para los próximos años Parecen ser
buenas para Rusia así es y lo
adelantábamos acá hace unos días porque
pues el fmi pues para este año augura
que Rusia crezca pese a las sanciones de
occidente y hoy el Ministerio de
economía de Rusia hizo lo propio y
revisó al alza su pronóstico del
producto interno bruto para 2023 con un
crecimiento del 1,2% desde la
contracción del
0,8%. Juan Pablo interesante vamos ahora
a hablar de china porque ha habido una
visita oficial de analena birebok la
ministra de exteriores de Alemania a
Beijing Aunque hablaron de temas
económicos muy poco en el encuentro pues
se centró en la guerra en Ucrania porque
pues en las últimas semanas ha aumentado
la presión internacional para empujar a
China a intervenir con Rusia y a
llevarla a la mesa de negociaciones hace
una semana el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron y la jefa De la comisión
europea Úrsula bonder Legend pidieron a
Beijing que desempeñe un papel para la
paz en Ucrania escuchemos
China y Alemania quieren cooperar y no
confrontarse ya sea una confrontación
directa o una confrontación grupal no se
debe permitir ninguna la cooperación
económica y comercial es la base de las
relaciones entre los dos países el
beneficio mutuo y la victoria la
dependencia chino alemana en la cadena
Industrial es el resultado Inevitable de
la globalización económica y la elección
óptima de acuerdo con las reglas del
mercado seguimos ahora Juan Pablo con
Los indicadores de las principales
bolsas pues hasta el momento en el que
abrió Wall Street abrió con pérdidas ya
que algunos de los bancos más grandes
del país registraron sólidas ganancias
en el primer trimestre Pero temerosos
porque las ventas minoristas de Estados
Unidos cayeron más de lo esperado en
marzo debido a que los consumidores
redujeron las compras de vehículos
motorizados y otros artículos costosos
lo que muestra que la economía está
perdiendo fuerza al final del primer
trimestre en Asia las bolsas reportaron
ganancias todavía motivadas por el dato
de inflación de Estados Unidos Que fue
mejor de lo esperado y opti por las
negociaciones comerciales que está
haciendo Beijing pues en estos días con
Brasil con Alemania como lo decíamos las
bolsas europeas Siguen operando con
ganancias con los datos positivos de
Alemania de inflación que salieron ayer
y con los de España y Francia que
veremos en segundos pues entonces datos
positivos para Alemania y España
repíteme esos datos que me gustaría
oírlas vamos a verlos uno de esos datos
le interesa a usted mucho ya lo decíamos
es el dato de España la inflación en
marzo pues o la variación de precios al
consumidor cayó hasta el 3,3% anual
desde el 6% que alcanzó en este mes el
segundo mes consecutivo de una
desaceleración y es el dato más bajo
desde agosto de 2021 este dato positivo
para la economía española estuvo
motivado por la caída de precios en la
vivienda electricidad gas y Transporte
Aunque un incremento en los precios de
las principales bebidas alcohólicas el
tabaco y para el sector de la recreación
y deporte que ya lo decíamos cuando
usted regrese a España pues hay que
revisar en va a invertir en recreación y
deporte yo solo en deporte nada de
alcohol nada de tabaco vamos con los
datos de la vecina Francia bueno los
franceses también se sentirán un pequeño
alivio en sus bolsillos porque en marzo
la inflación interanual cayó hasta el
5,7% desde el 6,3% de febrero llegando a
un mínimo de seis meses pero este dato
es una décima mayor de lo que esperaban
las autoridades financieras del país
bueno cerramos con la cifra del día y
las cifras son mil millones de dólares
ese ese aumento el monto que emiratos
árabes Unidos confirmó que entregará a
Pakistán como apoyo financiero según
confirmó el ministro de finanzas del
país beneficiado con esto Pakistán se
acerca más a la aprobación del fmi de
liberar el dinero que ha estado
represado durante meses porque el país
del sur de Asia pues necesita esta
aprobación china Arabia Saudita y ahora
de emiratos árabes Unidos han entregado
dinero a Pakistán pues Juan Pablo Muchas
gracias por este repaso económico le
deseo buen fin de semana y nos vemos el
lunes con mucho más con mucho más